thank you I'm good thank you
good I like a look at some stormtrooper
chic okay your skirt is different this
time last time wasn't it the lightsaber
skirt I remember I'm loving it that
memory
okay well the next I'm gonna get a fin
on there though oh no way what you got
that you don't want to see where - where
is that I want to know where do you have
a star where says nice you should go
when you go to the pavilion
yeah I don't know if I can do that they
would be really angry doesn't have a
star was he are you going full frontal
in this movie he might do you I mean you
know remember that shot that we saw in
the teaser trailer was just like his
upper chest so we might need to go down
and check out what's happening with his
body it's been okay no he's not okay
I mean he looked really messed up in
that kinda trailer I hope you get get
well soon fin I'm doing alright I'm Joey
I'm doing fine but feeling that oh yeah
I don't know buddy doing all right how
are you personally handling Hans death
given that Harrison Ford is your best
friend I mean me and Harrison have a
very interesting relationship and I'm
sure you notice from the last publicity
we just you know have like fun banter of
each other and the other day I posted
the April Fool
fools are in which harm comes into
Chewie and says Chewie and Jimmy's like
Han and takes off his mask and his fin
is like April yeah but you know after
after the emotional you know moment of
losing Han is great it's great to know
that you know he's he's gone on to the
to the force and you've gotta be one of
those people to you're like I'm gonna
make you like me dammit I gave him
random hugs all the time there's nothing
you could do about it I think you're
gonna be having a lot of scenes with
Kelly Marie Tran what he tell me about
the character dynamic and working with
her
I mean Kelly's character is an absolute
fan of fin which is so interested it
takes an interest in turn though but
they go closer the only the resistance
now you know you've got to think about
it
you know between seven and eight people
have now heard about the the amazing
finis done and now he's like you know
waving and saying hi it's all the you
know resistant ladies around and I
realize you know why is that kind of
transition it's crazy but it is it's a
fun time the dynamic between them is is
is is is very interesting me Finn sees a
lot of himself in her and she's still
trying to figure out her place you know
as Ryan said she's not a soldier she's
not a pilot so she's kind of figure out
what what what can she import that's
important to the good part and so they
both have to figure that out together
cannot wait to find out more yes thank
you so much thank you so much love you
forgot thank you and see you tomorrow
yeah
[Music]